so swear to god we are damned I might
die right here I thought about this
that's why right here dude I'm texting
it's Sean the [ __ ] face we all have
to we all have to think about this yeah
shit's getting crazy dude and the other
thing that we have to think of is how
quick can we bring it back to a
manageable place how quick does you come
in LA take to bounce back but I think in
LA what's gonna happen there see all
these other states open up and it's
gonna put so much pressure on Newsome
and Garcetti where they have no choice
man they have no you looking for the
numbers in Ohio Atlanta Florida they
have no Denver they have they're gonna
have San Diego there you have no [ __ ]
choice no one no one understands people
donut they're easily fooled with cases
and numbers they're so easily fooled
most people have no idea that 80,000
people died last year of the flu the
exact same symptoms the exact same death
of the people that are dying of Corona
it's the same gets that many but it's a
lot it's like 60 can you imagine can you
imagine it's it's like it's like um who
if they put the spotlight on us another
state there's about 200 strains of the
flu I'm not sure how many strains
there's a bunch right I thought I read
some toys me yeah how many people die
from rattlesnakes yeah there's all these
technical names
how many grizzly bears like car wrecks
if you car wrecks that's better you
should be [ __ ] driving well driving
we would be in a war spirits yes we
would be underwater against cigarettes
you know easy would be to ban driving
you know dude they just said all sports
and concerts done and it happened you
think they could just say driving make
driving illegal you don't think they're
gonna happen we're in the middle
world order right now we're in the
middle they shut everything down so
there should be nobody ever Sanderson
those guys Oh
all those guy anybody that says oh those
guys are they with their Corona
conspiracy theories with their Corona
dude we're the greatest conspiracy
theory of all time right now right now
is the greatest man everything got shut
down if I would have told you last year
dude next year everything's gonna you
would say every [ __ ] country let me
let me off you stop oh let me just
finish this real quick let me just
finish - stop 30 seconds apologize you
know what I'm saying is um if I would
have told you that a year ago I said
there's gonna be but if I would have
said there's gonna be a great if this
impeachment if this impeachment fails
they're gonna come hard with that last
hope because it's not you have to
realize how many people died versus how
many people were out there there's a big
difference between the way they
approached it if everybody was open in
society the way it was it would have
spread quicker it would have been more
people Florida says hold my margarita
Sweden says hold my margarita it's
slowed down the transmission to make
people aware if they wash their hands
more if they put masks on if they did
all that [ __ ] the beginning maybe it
slowed it down you got to think if that
number is higher it's like 80 something
thousand now right that number is higher
than the flu and they did that so it's
worse than the flu it's it is [ __ ]
dangerous if you're not healthy it's
[ __ ] dangerous can I explain some
here's what here's the alternative
perspective what you're thinking is some
grand conspiracy to overthrow Trump what
I think it is is they got some power
when we were forced to all collectively
decide to let them take the reins and
lock everyone down try to protect
ourselves from a very real virus
numbers of the virus are very real
assignment assigned the virus are very
real that's right but the problem is
human beings in power that's the problem
yeah I think I'm sorry with that we
thought we'd say these experts these
experts the scientists and and you know
Falchi those people are wrong a lot of
times by the government the defendant
they get paid by the joke he didn't see
it coming he went that's not a really
big deal we shouldn't be wearing masks
well because we had never had something
like this happen where we got bad
information from another country that
experience okay maybe like there's so
much [ __ ] going on in all these lies
certificates realistically though there
was when they when they had this moment
when they identified the World Health
Organization was saying that they also
didn't trust saying no they're not but
I'm saying that China was saying that
you couldn't get it from a person uh-huh
that it was oh it was only transmittable
from like that animal [ __ ] would we
listen they're not trustworthy nobody
that you mentioned is trustworthy one
way to mask a [ __ ] starts flying
around hard to figure out some [ __ ]
hey there's a lot of theories you gotta
go you just could you make a conclusion
and it's wrong doesn't mean you don't
make fun of the person that makes it
detectives they put together facts and
make conclusions some detectives go I
think it might be this guy the other
detective goes no it just probably his
brother and if someone's gonna be wrong
they're not gonna make fun of the other
person for being wrong honestly young
for the truth we're putting a sax
together a suicide when all I'm saying
is there's so much [ __ ] with the
padding of the numbers forging of the
death certificate I'm not a statistician
I don't know if those numbers are
accurate nobody knows but the fact that
it's a concern and I bet it's listen I
think the reality is it's probably
concerned both ways I bet a bunch of
people died and they didn't listen as
Cova know they get
I didn't I don't think they get paid if
they find a body no I think I get paid
more if it's not a hospital now would
they get paid they find him why would
they get it why would a hospital get
paid to have a coded death like why
would be why would that happen why does
the hospital get paid I think that
doesn't make any sense their money to
stay open because there's a massive
crisis that strange the resources in a
way that's unprecedented so they send
them a bunch of money yes is it strange
okay look a look at it like this Prime
look as soon as you establish that the
players like maybe you didn't know them
in the beginning you believed them
whatever and then now there's so much
obvious deceit and deception and lies at
that point you got to go oh okay we got
to go we got a backtrack maybe all this
[ __ ] is a deception and maybe there's
other reasons wait a minute you got some
point maybe everything was wrong I think
this was a Black Swan and it presented
itself and now as joe said the people in
power taking this as now consolidate no
I totally respect just like us or
controlling people deciding all I'm
saying is Brian that theory and what
your theory hey I'm not gonna make fun
of it these are all just theories no one
knows [ __ ] there's so much deception we
should all be going manikin maybe it's
that maybe it's that maybe it's that
maybe it's done not like a [ __ ] that
you're [ __ ] crazy dude this is all
mr. crazy [ __ ] of all sir